[Música]
cuáles son las noticias relacionadas con
la economía y cómo les va los mercados
pues se lo preguntamos a quien sabe de
este tema jorge hurtado que está aquí en
el estudio de france 24 y comenzamos
hablando de la condonación de deuda para
cerca de medio millón de estudiantes en
eeuu una muy buena noticia para sus
préstamos estudiantiles bueno santiago
se trata de la condonación de deuda más
grande jamás realizada por el
departamento de educación de ese país la
administración de by tim da un paso al
frente en el escándalo de fraude de
corriente en college institución
educativa con fines de lucro que se
declaró en bancarrota en el año 2015 a
todos los que se inscribieron en las
escuelas de la compañía se les borrará
su deuda estudiantil federal eliminando
así 5 mil 800 millones de dólares para
más de 560 mil prestatarios en su apogeo
corinthian era una de las mayores
empresas universitarias con fines de
lucro con más de 100 campus en más de
110.000 estudiantes en escuelas como
everest white age y health cuando la
vicepresidenta kamala harris era fiscal
general de california colaboró con la
administración de barack obama para
descubrir cómo los campus falsificaban
los datos sobre el éxito sus graduados
la escuela decía que los estudiantes
habían encontrado empleo gracias a ellos
aunque en realidad trabajaban en tiendas
o negocios de comida rápida el gobierno
anunció que aquellos que tengan un saldo
restante en su deuda con corinthians
también recibirán reembolsos de los
pagos ya realizados la casa blanca está
considerando también continuar con la
condonación de préstamos estudiantiles
de base amplia sea se habla de una base
de 10 mil dólares por todos los
prestatarios aunque aún esa cifra no
está definida esto dijo la
vicepresidenta hoy
estamos aquí para marcar un hito es un
hito en un viaje que muchos de nosotros
hemos estado recorriendo durante
bastante tiempo un viaje por la justicia
para todos los que fueron defraudados
por corinthians college estudiantes que
simplemente querían mejorar sus
perspectivas en la vida y que en cambio
se encontraron con que se aprovecharon
de una estafa que les quitó su dinero y
no les dio nada a cambio excepto dolor
y seguimos hablando de eeuu así otro
banquero se pronunció
respecto a la economía de ese país esto
es positivo o negativamente jorge pues
en la misma línea de lo que
mencionábamos ayer sobre las palabras de
jamie dimon de jpmorgan que
pronosticaban huracán económico en esa
misma línea un alto ejecutivo de goldman
sachs group prevé tiempos más difíciles
en medio de una serie de crisis que
sacuden la economía mundial según jon
gualdrón presidente de goldman este es
uno de los más de los entornos más
complejos y dinámicos que ha visto en su
carrera calderón es uno de los más
críticos con la reserva federal de eeuu
desde el sector bancario según el
ejecutivo a la fed le falta autonomía
para soportar la presión de la inflación
más alta de los últimos 40 años en ese
país jorge 50% en un aumento de la
producción es lo que anunció la opep y
rusia estamos hablando de producción de
petróleo por supuesto si la producción
para los países acordaron que en julio y
agosto de este año aumentarán su
producción de petróleo en 648 mil
barriles diarios adicionales con esta
subida la opep y sus aliados entre ellos
por supuesto rusia devolverán al mercado
los casi 10 millones de barriles diarios
que recortaron en abril del 2020 en
respuesta a la caída del además por las
restricciones de la pandemia de
coronavirus el anuncio se da tras la
vida del bombeo ruso debido a las
sanciones occidentales por la invasión
de ucrania ya los llamados de los países
consumidores para elevar esta producción
de la opep y de esta forma frenar los
altos precios de la energía el precio
del crudo que ha rondado los 120 dólares
el barril se encuentra en su nivel más
alto en una década porque es interesante
lo que está pasando en el salvador
porque por ejemplo standard and poor's
bajó la calificación de este país
centroamericano por temores respecto al
financiamiento que tiene esta nación que
lo que está pasando allí bueno y esta es
la segunda agencia calificadora que baja
la evaluación de riesgo o que reduce la
calificación del país centroamericano
por las crecientes necesidades de
financiación para cubrir las brechas
presupuestarias y pagar la deuda de 800
millones de dólares que se vencen en
enero del próximo año según la agencia
las nuevas calificaciones crediticias de
riesgo soberano de largo plazo en moneda
local y extranjera son csc más de un ve
- previo y la perspectiva es negativa
para el salvador es amp y dice que esta
calificación
refleja las debilidades institucionales
del país según ellos este país
centroamericano tiene finanzas públicas
débiles y una carga de deuda muy alta
que ronda el 80 por ciento de su
producto interno bruto pasamos ahora a
los indicadores como las faldas
principal las bolsas y parques del
planeta bueno empezamos con world tour
que cerró con una fuerte subida liderada
por test la envidia y otros valores de
crecimiento de media capital en una
sesión sobre todo agitada y pendiente
del dato del empleo que se va a publicar
este viernes la bolsa de milán cerró al
alza durante una sesión con pocos
intercambios al ser día festivo en
italia y en américa latina la bolsa
mexicana de valores registró una pérdida
del 10 4% en su principal indicador
llegó de esta forma a su cuarta jornada
consecutiva cerrando en negativo con un
acumulado de menos dos como 84 por
ciento porque muchas gracias por esta
actualización del mundo económico a
continuación aquí en directo américa al
debate siga con nosotros